i am losing my mind over this news
flower arrangement
look at this so i know isn't this
amazing
i just want to thank our friends at
fetterbain
the philly flower shop that made this
for us wow really phenomenal work
beautiful ladies who own the business
are here and i
asked them if it would be okay i would
love to feature you guys
on our small business gift guide and if
you go to the drewberrymoreshow.com
you will see their beautiful business
and you too
can work with them as well oh your mug
runneth over
i mean we are spending a sending a
special congrats to the team
at fetterbain too because they're going
to be first-time exhibitors at this
year's iconic philadelphia flower show
so june 5th through june 13th they're
having in the philly area of this
extraordinary flower
expo so you get your tickets now and
they've been doing it for 193
years well for real yes okay they know
what they're doing then
i know it's a real beautiful tradition
and the activities and exhibits spread
across
15 acres of philly's fdr
park so this is a great story and thank
you for enlightening me about this i
really want to go and visit and see it
and next we're actually going to head
down to philly ourselves and
meet today's very special drew gooder
our friend
david begno of cbs this morning
filled in to do this report
hey i'm josh i live in philadelphia
pennsylvania i'm 24 years old and i am
the founder of new york bagel butler
i'm originally from long island new york
where i grew up eating bagels all my
life and when i moved down here there
was just nothing like it
i had a lightbulb moment while i had a
dozen bagels that i brought back from
new york on my counter and i was like
hey
why don't i just make this into a
business and from that point on
the first week i had i want to say about
11 dozen bagels delivered to people and
now we're averaging at about a hundred
dozen per week
the business started in june of 2020
main pandemic time
i wanted to give back in some way and i
figured might as well give back
food right now we're up to nearly 5 000
bagels donated a lot of this is also
like it comes out of my pocket because i
know how many people are out there who
need food who are struggling
it's a little bit extra work but it's
definitely worth it
[Music]
hey drew it's david bagno with cbs news
i heard about what drew good or josh is
doing
so i thought let's surprise him on your
behalf of course so we drove to philly
with a surprise
and we thought we'd show up in style
so tell me about yourself i was working
at a law firm uh working from home and
had this light bulb moment why don't i
just start breathing he is
oh my god how are you
i'm good oh my i'm sorry i'm just a
little bit um shocked we wanted to
surprise you that's from drew barrymore
oh my god thank you so much this is so
cool so let's see what we got
oh drew gooder that looks so good wow
oh my god flowers there we go wow i
actually could not do it without this
this is so helpful you don't understand
there's something infectious about
giving back and
when i saw your story i was inspired
like i was inspired to do something
myself where did you get the inspiration
to do what you're doing
philadelphia itself has one of the the
highest food and security rates at like
21
right now it's like one in five people
don't know where they're getting their
next meal problem
and kovit only made that like a bigger
problem so when i had the idea to just
bring bagels down as a business i made
sure that i was like foundationally
built into the business
to donate to give back so what are you
doing here so right now i'm actually
donating some bagels to one of my
drop-off spots
the block gives back where they give
back to local communities
one more surprise okay come on let's go
so the dru show colors are yellow okay
and we thought why don't we ride up in a
yellow car
and uh 500 bagels for you brother oh my
god that is a lot of bagels liberty
bagels nyc
donating 500 bagels so you
can pass it on actually this is insane
i'm like actually so overwhelmed because
there are a lot of hungry people in
philadelphia that need their bagels
time to drop off some donations wanna
come with me yeah let's do it
here we go bagel delivery
oh come on joining us this morning
cbs this morning's lead national
correspondent and dear friend of our
show
david beckner hi david
thank you for having me back at your
news destroyer i love you being here
can we do it once a week or something
and ditto and ditto well anytime
someone um breaks out a bagel i freak
out
i mean how did people react to that
bagel delivery what a wonderful
gentleman
he look he's um his mother was actually
the one who sort of
inspired the give back philosophy when
he was young and i called him right
before i came out here and i said how's
it going
he said my tire flattened on the bridge
and leaving new york going into
philadelphia and now my deliveries are
delayed but i called all my people and
they said it's okay
he's a one-man show it's a 20 year old
guy 24 year old
just trying to make a living give philly
some good bagels to to eat
and um he's just so likable i love i
love a man who's passionate about bagels
i think a good bagel isn't a real
a religious experience and not just
because they're holy
what do you like on yours i like cream
cheese online i see that you have
peanut butter on yours which i'm not
angry about i'm a peanut butter guy
david we heard you were mr peanut butter
on bagel and i was like
i've never done is that weird is that
weird no i love it i'll do butter on
bagel
i mean i'm definitely a smear girl i
love a lot of chives too like a scallion
cream cheese oh bro give it to me but
and
to see someone like that to take what
they're passionate about and use it to
help others
is so inspiring what was like the
biggest takeaway you got
after meeting him uh that someone his
age could feel the desire to give that
strongly
and i think the ability to want to give
back is timeless and it's ageless
right and so that that's what i took
away from him i just want to know
everything his mom did so that i can do
that as a parent
a good mama because can you imagine how
proud
his mom is and i just have to say as one
mother to another
what an incredible job you did raising
your son
because he is a good human being
someone we all want to be more like and
thank you david begno
for like bringing him to light these are
the kind of people i need to know about
good people are doing good things we're
going to be okay
uh-huh can we have a bite ready all
right
here we go did you guys think i was not
gonna eat the bagels
love you both cheers i'm seriously tired
of peanut butter have you ever had a
peanut butter bag i haven't you gotta
try it
so can i yeah
how do you eat breakfast ladies and
gentlemen welcome to mr ed
review a lot okay thank you
oh my gosh
[Music]